bolsonaro será investigado por su
gestión de la crisis sanitaria
así lo determinó el tribunal supremo de
brasil el magistrado luis roberto
barroso del tribunal supremo federal
determinó este jueves que el senado
adopte las medidas necesarias para la
instalación de la comisión de
investigación parlamentaria para
investigar posibles comisiones del
gobierno federal en la batalla contra la
pandemia de kobe 19 algunos senadores
llevaban meses tratando de abrir la
comisión unos intentos frustrados por
representantes aliados de bolsonaro sin
embargo la semana que viene se abrirá la
investigación
bolsonaro ha sido uno de los dirigentes
más escépticos con la gravedad de la
pandemia de kobe 19 desde que lo llamó
una gripe cita al inicio de la crisis
hasta el miércoles que volvió a rechazar
imponer una cuarentena no ha cambiado
mucho sólo recientemente modelo su tono
frente a las restricciones
buscamos un término medio unas
directrices que nos sirvan para no
perder más trabajos
mientras tanto brasil registró un nuevo
máximo histórico de fallecidos 4 mil 249
víctimas mortales en una sola jornada
el país había superado la barrera de las
4000 muertes por primera vez en toda la
pandemia el martes pasado los hospitales
empiezan a ver cómo escasea el oxígeno y
los medicamentos tres cuartos de los
hospitales privados solo tienen
suministros para una semana más y los
cementerios también están desbordados
solo en sao paulo la mayor ciudad del
país ya se cavan 600 tumbas diarias